so uh why the name change uh from better
angels to
bravery angels was there like a process
behind that well yeah so it was a couple
of things i like bravery angels by the
way i don't you know well good i'm glad
it actually was my uh my my name child
um and uh there are two things that
happened one was
once again
trademark
dispute someone didn't like better
angels yeah no somebody somebody with
more money than we had was a bit upset
about that and things were ultimately
resolved amicably so you know it's it's
okay but
um we had to step away from the original
name and you know the name better angels
is uh taken from abraham lincoln
quotation you know abraham lincoln yeah
i thought this was from yeah well yeah
that's absolutely right it was uh you
know uh
referenced um you know touching the
better angels of our nature
in his first inaugural address on the
eve of the civil war right trying to
sort of stave off the the apocalypse
that was to was to come
so better angels that's where the name
original name came from i advocated for
a shift to braver angels for two reasons
one of them practical uh being the fact
that i thought a similar sounding name
would allow us to preserve as much brand
recognition as we could right
they're close right i'd assume they're
the same exactly so you know on that
front it seemed like a sound choice but
also
you know
there is uh something of uh you don't
prefer what's that courageous angels now
i'm kidding
well maybe the trademark is available
probably you know
um but the other but the more
substantive
reason was you know there is a cottage
industry of
um
you know philanthrop well of of
nonprofit organizations and foundations
committed to depolarization and bridge
building work this field is now in the
last few years expanded rapidly other
players because everyone's redemption
right and so it's now becoming more sort
of firmly
formed and it's maturing but you but
you've had sort of a cottage you know uh
sector for a while doing this kind of
work within which you know the value and
virtue of empathy has always been
foundational and this is the thing that
is destroying us in my opinion is that
if someone's your
ideological enemy uh they're now
not just worthless as a human being
they're actually
not human or dehumanized uh and so
whatever vitriol you directed them is
somehow now justified right like that
that's the core problem
yeah well it is it is and there's so
much more we can say about that but the
reason and owing to that fact
you know in this sort of sector as it
had existed you know there is naturally
a deep sort of emphasis on the value of
empathy in being sort of the spirit that
guides bridge building work and of
course because you know in order to
really develop a deep relationship of
trust with you
if especially if we are tribal you know
opposites it's gonna be important for me
to be able to demonstrate the fact that
i can kind of you know put myself in
your shoes to sort of see things as you
see things and demonstrate the fact that
i you know have some understanding of
who you are what's important to you and
that i care enough to have that
understanding and demonstrated so the
emphasis on empathy is is needed but
it it had long been evident to me that
to really
pursue this work
into sort of the heat of america's
tribal and political conflicts which is
where it needs to go
it takes more than just being empathetic
you really do need courage you really do
need bravery increasingly unfortunately
well and and for for two uh two
immediate reasons one the most obvious
one is that you try and reach out to
people who have you know
uh
have been culturally kind of like you
know pitted against you
there's gonna be oftentimes a level of
distrust uh towards you and maybe even a
tendency towards being a little bit mean
towards you maybe just on the basis just
maybe just on the basis of the fact that
you're from the other party but
people in your own party your own
comrades and compatriots
will oftentimes look at you with some
degree of suspicion
and maybe even you know a sense that
you've sold out you know on the basis of
the fact that you do choose to empathize
with people who think differently
because people on each side are you know
to whatever degree find themselves
committed to the notion that look i
can't i can't
you know for those people yeah exactly
socialize with with these people i can't
keep company with them because if i do
i'm entertaining fascists if i do i'm
entertaining people who hate america
right and if you're doing that and you
say you agree with me but you're friends
with them that i've got a little bit of
suspicion towards you too so bravery
wound up being a necessary point of
emphasis and i think that it helped to
to fortify the message of braver angels
in a way that has been more empowering
for people who have come into our ranks
and has had influences on the larger
space as well i agree and i like it and
i want to
affirm
that one of the most noxious beliefs
nowadays is that if i sit with you
then somehow i'm vouching for everything
you believe in about everything under
the sun and if there's one other
statement that's like oh
you you know
hung out with that person and thus you
blessed everything about them and if
they don't you know like the entire
thing is like yeah well you know i talk
to people in real life all the time and
like you know
i don't agree with everything that
um that they say uh and there's a word
that bugs me
and it's funny now because i i you know
i'm something of a public figure and i i
like have um uh a platform but this term
platforming it's like oh you platformed
this person right you've like given them
uh
elevation giving them legitimacy
legitimacy it's like you bless this
person who is intrinsically illegitimate
and you're just like you know
like like when did sitting with someone
somehow
like have this kind of weight to it
where like you're like oh you can't talk
to that person and there's so many
people
now who
uh suffer and struggle with this where
there's like oh you know it's like i i
can't be seen with this person like it's
really
uh it's worse than counterproductive
there are two things i mean there are
multiple things but there there there
are two things that i'll mention that
are intersecting i think it's like how
the heck are you gonna bring people
together if you're like not allowed to
you know have a conversation well that's
the thing it's fine for many folks
there's a limit to the value of bringing
people together right and so there are
two things that i see sort of
intersecting here that are that are most
salient you know one is the fact that
we've come to a point now in american
life where as opposed to times past
where republicans and democrats you know
different parties but there's very
little like deep-seated social animosity
between the parties you know um yeah i
mean you know back in the 50s and 60s
you know
there were polls taken i think at least
in the 60s asking the question if your
child married a republican or a democrat
would you care and it's like five
percent of americans cared people were
were you know but if they were catholic
right
i'm not sure what the exact figure is
but is well upwards of fifty percent
yeah that was 52 yeah yeah yeah i think
it's upwards of 50
um now nobody cares what religion you
are it's a question of what you know
what your political party well politics
is the new religion well yes and
unfortunately media tribes when i was
sitting with arthur brooks he
said that like media tribes are the new
uh many religions well so the difference
is you're forming a new mini religion
well
civic religion is a phrase that has some
history to it you might be i don't you
maybe you know eric liu uh yeah yeah so
there's some eric talks about
but
so the differences between us have
extended to being beyond the pale for
people in a way to where you know it's
not just that we have a good faith
disagreement about something that's
important but we have a you know i can
infer at least that we have a moral
disagreement on things that are
characterologically determinative of
your value as a human being in some
respects right and so that makes us not
want to interact but you couple that
with the fact that we live in an
attention economy within which we are
competing for space to be heard we have
more opportunities and more platforms to
be heard than ever but the competition
over that i think is probably fiercer
than it has ever been and so i think
people have a sense of okay if you have
a platform holy [ __ ] we all want a
platform especially a platform that
people actually come to
and so if you have a platform you have
ethical responsibility you've got to use
that resource you know wisely you know
if you put give that resource to
somebody who's going to use it to
advance systemic racism just for for
example you know
um
then you are you know
you are investing
in
that uh anti-human project you're
investing in that project of hate uh and
so you know um the intensity of sort of
the competition within the kind of you
know information and and you know
attention economy
meets this moral paranoia and i don't
say moral paranoia to be dismissive of
it because you know look i i
i get it i mean people have deeply felt
reasons for not wanting to elevate you
know milo yiannopoulos or whoever you
know whoever it is you're you're talking
about well i guess we've all forgotten
about milo at this point um
that's a fine example i got it oh yeah
right um
but it yes it's created this context in
which we need to now make the case for
why it is utterly imperative not just
for the survival of democracy but also
for the advancement to put in the racial
justice context of a larger uh project
of of equity and equality and social
justice in american life to be able to
engage our neighbors yes right in
constructive discourse we have to make
that case a new now in 2022 yeah that
that's the case i'm making as well
[Music]
you